russia's invasion of ukraine has
triggered a historic mass movement of
people not seen in europe in decades
more than a million people have already
freed the country according to the un's
refugee agency and that number is
growing by the day
among those fleeing russia's bombs are
african students studying at
universities in ukraine according to
ukrainian officials there were about 16
000 of them before the conflict began
some of them have reported receiving
racist treatment from ukrainian
officials who they say pushed them back
as they tried to flee
now some african students are still in
ukraine and trying to get out and others
are in other european countries some
have left for africa like one medical
student who is now safely back home in
ghana she shared her experience with us
together again
priscilla ajar and her father samuel
after a terrifying week
the fifth year medical student was
studying at a university in western
ukraine when the war broke out
it was very tough it was horrible like
i remember i was shivering literally
when my like my school said that okay
you guys could go home i was like which
means that the school sees the intensity
of it now
there was similar fear back home in
ghana her family was closely monitoring
events in faraway ukraine and not for
the first time
the anxiety is a reminiscent of what
happened in 2014
because in 2014
my son was also in donetsk
and the same
issue happened and they had to virtually
run from the next to the capital kiev so
when the second one also started from
last week
a whole lot of
anxiety emotional
trauma let's put it that way the entire
family was put into that
priscilla made for the border closest to
her city
and we took a bus so after we just took
a bus and then we after some time the
buses were not moving vehicles are not
moving anymore so we had to trek for i
think over over an hour and a half
yes so that's how we got to the border
and then the water
it was messy
so many people ukrainians ghanaians
nigerians zimbabweans
egyptians indians everybody everybody in
chelsea is going there
she crossed into romania and like many
other ghanaian students
made it back home safely
but priscilla still has major concerns
as the war escalates in ukraine
so let's say that they destroy
everything in the country the country
has to go through redevelopmental stages
again so what is
what what like what's at stake for us i
don't know if our school buildings will
be destroyed whatever
so it's quite
burdensome and it's worrying very
worrying
that we don't know if we can go back to
school if we would finish
if we would complete are we going to go
back to square one for what the answers
might not come for a while
but being with family can be the great
comfort priscilla and others like her
need right now
now priscilla edgar and others are
safely home now but many others are not
while some have made it out of ukraine
and are now in neighboring countries
there are still some african nationals
stuck in ukraine and trying to get out
earlier i spoke to husseini uma madakawi
he's a chairperson of the nigerian
diaspora in hungary he was at the border
between hungary and ukraine
that we are here
to assist nigerians guide them
how to get to the city
we brought along with us from budapest
some humanitarian clothes
some winter clothes
and
some good items
for those who arrived from
ukraine
we help them
uh
guide them
where
the
connections
here
uh we were hearing or have been hearing
accounts of africans trying to leave
ukraine they've been reporting that
they've been not allowed into trains
leaving ukraine they say they've
experienced racism and ill treatment
from ukrainian officials that are on the
ground
are you still hearing accounts is this
still continuing to happen as people try
to leave ukraine
well uh we hear about this uh situation
but we cannot verify it because our job
is limited to uh coming to hungarian
border what's happening
at the ukrainian buddha we we have no
idea but we have people
um
calling and making complaints that they
are being taken off from the train from
the buses
but we don't know for what what reason
husseini how many people do you know of
that are still in ukraine and want to
get out what are they telling you
it's very difficult to predict how many
people
are still in ukraine because we don't
have the actual number of of them before
now
so by all i know that
it's not only me all the executives of
needle
uh hungary
we share our phone numbers they are
calling us getting uh
uh
to get information
on what to do
uh how to come from hungary
and what help can we offer that we tell
them
what we can do for them and uh some
parents of course out of uh desperation
they are calling and crying and telling
us that
their children
are
dying their children
are in the border and they don't know
what to do we try to calm them down
and tell them we are on top of the
situation
in synchron with the embassy
we are trying to do our best
to see what we can do for them how we
can help them we
guide many of them to the hotel to a
place where the charity organization
is providing shelter for them the needle
hungry now provide food for them we have
volunteers who go there to cook for them
and we should hear all the pictures of
what we
yes
sorry we're talking about the people who
are still in ukraine right now we'll
talk about those that have left
but for those who are still in ukraine
what kind of support do they need to
leave
uh many of them are on their way
so the question they asked mainly is
that
which is the easiest order for them
to cross
so as i told you earlier that as they
are scattered there in ukraine in
different cities whichever border is
closer for them to go that's where they
will advice
so we don't receive them to come into
hungary because um
some of them
are not closer to hungarian water
okay
and for those that have now managed to
get out and are not some are in poland
slovakia and others
in hungary where you are what is their
situation there
the situation is still uh
chaotic
we're trying to gather them
register them
put them in the hotel we have charity
organizations that offer
uh
including some
these three countries of our places for
those coming in
to to accommodate them for a
short period of time and we are just
directing them there
that was husseini uma madakawi speaking
to us from the border between hungary
and ukraine now
the first group of more than 400
nigerians evacuated from ukraine have
landed in abuja
the group comprised mostly of students
they arrived on a government chartered
flight from romania's capital bucharest
they are among 14 000 nigerian nationals
who were known to be in ukraine
before the war began that's according to
the nigerian foreign ministry's figures
now it is unclear if and when
they can go back
to ukraine